gary is deputy prime minister and
finance minister uh asan vasilev joins
me now from sophia uh good afternoon and
good to have you with us speaking here
on sky news
just let's get your reaction first to
this move by russia
uh well uh bulgaria has been uh
following the contract exactly
as we have been for the last 10 years
and
we had the russian side trying
umilaterally to impose uh changes to the
payment terms uh in other terms in the
contract which we uh refused and
requested clarification on why that's
necessary
and
as a result what we saw is we received
the letter yesterday today we were cut
off from uh
deliveries uh on the part of gazprom
which has been
a long-standing supplier of gas to
bulgaria
ursila vonderlein says that uh
europe has been prepared for this they
were expecting this there are plenty of
alternatives
what are they what what is bulgaria's
alternative to this right now
so we had about
between two thirds and three quarters of
the gas delivered by russia since
february we've put alternative plans in
place uh we have uh large existing
interconnectivity with greece and turkey
so as of right now we receive part of
the gas from azerbaijan through
connectivity in greece we are also
receiving gas from lng terminals in
greece and working on receiving gas
homology terminals in turkey
and
we've also circulated the non-paper at
the european union level uh because
poker is a relatively small gas market
about three and a half billion cubic
meters
but our interconnectivity allows for gas
to flow from south to north
of about 20 22 billion cubic meters so
we can be part of the solution not only
for bulgaria but also for
southeastern europe uh in general and
we've also had some you say that but
bulgaria depends on russia for 77 of
your gas supply this is a significant
hit for your country isn't it
now as of today we have zero percent
russian gas we haven't limited any gas
supply to any of our industries or any
of our people
and we have
activated the alternative routes and
sources um so as i said since february
we've been ready for this moment we were
hoping it would not come in that russia
downwards contracts but it came
and we haven't had any interruption in
supply we don't expect any interruption
in supply uh and as i said um about a
month ago we pushed for a common
european purchasing strategy on gas
because for lmg in those quantities you
need careful scheduling and large scale
deliveries
bulgaria has done its own
supply reservations in the lmg terminals
as well as all the pipelines that we
need to get the gas from greece and 32
bulgaria
but
in addition to our three billion cubic
meters we can
take supply from the southern gas
corridor as well as lng terminals in
greece and turkey to the tune of about
20 billion cubic meters that can then go
to
romania and from there to the rest of
europe or go to serbia
hungary and then to the rest of europe
we've even had
discussions
sorry i didn't want to talk across you
um the the kremlin has released a
statement saying that you know it's a
simple matter of bulgaria paying in
rubles this is what they have asked for
all along you know they are a reliable
energy supplier and it doesn't engage in
blackmail your response to that
it's a simple matter of following the
contract
the contract says we pay in u.s dollars
in a specific account in gazprom bank
any change to the contract done
unilaterally regardless of how nicely
it's requested or how nicely it's not
requested
visa change of contract which the other
party needs to agree
we haven't agreed to that change of
contract
which means that russia is now breaking
the contract and we will obviously go to
international trash court
to seek for damages
why do you think bulgaria
has been targeted in this way
specifically
uh i don't think bulgaria is being
targeted uh poland bulgaria and my
understanding is lithuania were the
first countries
that had payments due to
gas problem
i think the other countries that are
coming up with payments if they follow
the strategy of
paying exactly as per contract and not
accepting unilateral contract changes
would probably face the same situation
do you think it might be because
bulgaria is involved in providing
military equipment to ukraine
i don't think there is a link between
the two
we've seen at for example turkey
providing very vital military equipment
to ukraine and we haven't heard about
any gas supplies getting cut to turkey
would you consider paying in rubles to
russia i mean how long can you
carry on with these alternative methods
for
forever uh no we will not play in rurals
what you seem pretty frustrated and
angry in in the way russia has dealt
with this situation
well i think we've had bilateral
relations that are constructive and
what we've seen is a unilateral breach
of contract
that obviously doesn't make us happy i
wouldn't say we're angry we were
prepared for that because we've had
similar incidents in 2009 uh 2014 um so
we
were one of the first in the european
union to get the to push for contingency
plans for deliveries we've made our
contingency plans our gas from contracts
expires at the end of this year anyways
so
basically what we see going forward is
zero russian gas in our economy
while i have you i'd like to ask you
about
what you feel about the situation on the
ground in ukraine what's happening and
where this is all headed
um it's a terrible human tragedy that
we're seeing the fact that we have uh
targeting of civilians uh i think is
um
beyond belief uh and
something which cannot be justified with
any rhetoric
on on the russian side
we support the ukraine firmly we support
all the sanctions we are pushing for
strict sanctions to be imposed on russia
and um we think that uh right now
there is a lot of focus that is done on
delivering equipment which is very
important for ukraine um i think also we
need to start thinking and planning
ahead for the incoming winter
where there will need to be a lot of
logistical work that needs to be done
making sure there is sufficient food
supply making sure ukraine can receive
sufficient gas to heat its people and
keep its economy going
making sure that all the logistical
corridors work
all of those are critical matters that
if we wait until september october or
november would be too late we need to
start preparing for that now and we
actually had some conversations with the
ukrainian minister of finance and how we
might be able to help there
we have a delegation led by our prime
minister uh going to meet with mr
zelensky tomorrow which is focused
exactly on those issues
beyond the military conflict and weapons
which seem pretty much at hand at this
point uh how can we move to the next
part which is making sure the ukrainian
economy is stable and that the incoming
winter which is going to be very tough
uh regardless of when the war ends
is properly planned for and that the
ukrainians have all the food all the
energy supplies
and all the existing infrastructure
logistics wise to be able to
make sure that their people are
actually cared for
deputy prime minister asan vasilev
thanks very much indeed for speaking to
us here on sky news thank you